the American Constitution is brief but
it has many important conditions equal
protection of the law protection of
fundamental rights free speech and
expression repress right against
unreasonable search and seizure like to
a lawyer right to fair criminal process
there are many in there so it preserves
democratic institutions in preserves
basic human rights
it divides power among three branches of
government legislation Congress
executive president and the judicial
court supreme court and lower courts it
does that so no one will get too much
power the difference when you're
interpreting in text whether it's a
statute or the Constitution is the
question of emphasis all judges I
believe you'll find your but your judges
in all important graphs or anything they
all think about the same thing in the
sense that they all think that there are
six important tools that they use to
interpret attacks is that what it is
saying that's the first thing you beget
what it's ending if you said something
about vegetables that doesn't include
rabbits so you're limited by text but if
the case in this court is very unlikely
the text is clear otherwise why does
this come to different conclusions so
there's the text there is a history
everyone links the history is relevant I
think the history is relevant and you
look at it what is the history of this
provision of this statute of course you
look at that tradition habeas corpus is
a word with some real tradition in the
mayor
in English law and elsewhere of course
you look at the traditions precedent
what a judges say in the past we all try
to follow precedent but if precedent
history and tradition and X we're clear
enough why do we have a case I think
also everyone will agree that we look to
the purpose what is the purpose of this
provision why in someone write it they
had a reason and consequences if you
decide this way how in fact will you
further the purpose or for reading if
you decide that way what consequences
will flow and how will they affect the
purpose of this set so everyone looks to
those six things history text present
tradition constant God purposes or
values and consequence some emphasize
the first or the history the text they
emphasize it for it even easier to rely
on her to find others like me emphasize
the latter to purpose value consequence
focus more it is the question of degree
Justice Scalia gaudy hardly ever look
the purposes at least discuss this and
in the publicly and matzevot here's a
case for you didn't said only completely
of course not in a famous case which I
was in dissenting saying that the Second
Amendment protected a right to maintain
a gun in a home he thought that the
origin of the early founders of the
company of the Constitution wrote the
Second Amendment which said you have a
right to bear arms to protect that kind
of thing
my side of it the dissenters read the
same history and we came to the opposite
conclusion we thought they were
interested in protecting the rights of
states to maintain
malicious right and so a history doesn't
in my opinion very often give us the
answer it does sometimes but everybody
will get into propria cases so when you
read the media while you're reading
people who are most in politics and what
they're doing is they like to emphasize
their differences but really there is
much more similarity than people